the world needed a hero it got Black
Adam but did it get a good movie there's
no one on this planet that can stop me
through Alice's Hollywood career Dwayne
The Rock Johnson has done more than most
actors will in their lifetime he joins
The Fast and Furious family as Luke
Hobbs revived the Jumanji series for a
new generation of moviegoers and
infamously fought Rick O'Connell as a
half-human half scorpion CGI monstrosity
but he's come a long way since that
Rocky start and now he's joining the
ranks of superheroes as the anti-hero
teth Adam in DC's Black Adam even though
he signed on to play the character in a
shazam movie way back in 2007 it took 15
years to complete his journey to the
screen the story of his solo film
follows Adam as he breaks his thousands
of years long imprisonment to wreak
havoc on the modern world in response to
Justice Society of America takes it upon
themselves to not only stop his
destruction but teach him what it means
to be a hero after all they have a
bigger fish to fry in the form of the
way more villainous Ishmael Gregor AKA
sabak
days ahead of the theatrical release of
Black Adam some reviewers got to see the
movie early sadly in the eyes of many
the movie wasn't worth the wait here's
what early reviews have to say about
Black Adam I kneel before no one well
the score fluctuated on Rotten Tomatoes
as new reviews came in Black Adam has
wound up with a genuinely rotten critic
score with 54 percent of reviewers
having a positive opinion as of the
making of this video even the positive
reviews are a little middling and
according to critics the film has some
fundamental issues the New York Post
Johnny olexinski spared nothing in a
negative review saying it's just as
Thoughtless and rancid as the rest of DC
Comics crummy catalog according to the
critic Black Adam suffers from poor
dialogue and underdeveloped characters
complains that several other pundits
would have as well Alonso derral day of
the rap honed in on the film supporting
characters writing knowing nothing about
the Justice society and its members
doesn't make them particularly
interesting adversaries for our
anti-hero protagonist deadlines Tom
McCarthy adds that the film has a bad
habit of letting flashy special effects
to the talking instead of taking the
proper time to flesh out the characters
and story something else about black
garden that critics can't look past is
the overall quality relative to how long
it took to get made Brian Truett of USA
Today wrote this is Dwayne Johnson's
Baby a film spotlighting a complicated
anti-hero he gets championed for years
it wins some battles and packs plenty of
punch yet it just can't get past
familiar tropes and flaws Matt Rodriguez
from Shake fire compared the movie
itself to the marketing for it stating
it's not awful especially when compared
to many of the other dceu films but it's
far from the game changer it claims to
be while it may sound like a Black Adam
is a huge swing and a miss with critics
thus not entirely the case more than a
few early reviews have found something
to praise in the feature Jeff Nelson of
Showbiz cheat sheet wrote of his
appreciation for Dwayne Johnson's
performance claiming that the Black Adam
character shows loads of potential
collider's roster name was more lukewarm
on the movie but still felt like it
might be a decent Foundation to build on
the critic wrote It's a welcome shift
for this larger world and an
invigorating look at the potential going
forward in this universe Greg katzman
from comic book resources also gave
Johnson praise for his take on Black
Adam writing Johnson does the character
Justice and dials a Charisma bag for a
performance that is badass brutal
confident and determined with just the
right amount of death and dry humor
meanwhile Ben roethl discussing film
says Black Adam is a thoroughly
entertaining ride that makes for an
awesome experience on the biggest screen
one can find all in all Black Adam seems
like a mixed bag of a film with more
negatives to its name than positives but
if you walk in with the right
expectations you just might find
something to enjoy
[Music]